some of the residents in silver stone
ranch in the northwest part of town are
being asked to join a virtual Town Hall
now according to a Facebook post the
topic is the closed Golf Course right in
the middle of this community as 8 news
now reporter Joe Moller explains some
residents are not happy with the online
Town Hall idea
I picked the house for the open space
Pat spilatro says he paid a $70,000 lot
premium for his silver stone ranch home
back in 2006 I get sick when I look at
her it absolutely it just turns my
stomach when I look at her a few years
ago the course was purchased and then
shut down there's a deed restriction
that says there's supposed to be a 27
hole Championship golf course out there
he says the Golf Course has been a legal
issue for years basically were in
mediation we're supposed to look at this
plan in this meeting and supposed to
vote on it at some time he showed us a
flyer he got in the mail regarding the
future of the Golf Course a proposal
that would be a sale of nine holes
millions of dollars in legal fees
returned to homeowners and 18 holes
would be deeded to the HOA
at the top it says there will soon be a
vote spilatro says there was a plan to
develop more houses on parts of the
course we don't want any more houses in
the neighborhood I post on a silver
stone ranch home owners association
Facebook page shows there was an
upcoming virtual town hall to discuss
the golf course according to the post it
is being hosted by the owners of the
Golf Course Stone Ridge Parkway LLC so
they're going to present their offer and
then we have to vote some residents are
not happy with a virtual idea John
Bradford says he is worried about his
home he bought to retire in the most
they can put on zoom' as a thousand and
there's fifteen hundred and twenty-six
homeowners so it's they'll be
interesting to see how how that plays
out but it's just going to be a watch
only no question-and-answer that virtual
Town Hall is taking place next Thursday
June 4th at 6:30 p.m. there's details on
how to log in on the Association
Facebook page
reporting in silver stone ranch Joe
Meaux 8 News now by the way we reached
out to the communications company that's
listed on that flyer I sent to the
homeowners they told us that they are
working to get some questions answered
we also reached out to the silver stone
ranch HOA for more information about
that meeting and we have yet to receive
their response